all right james
what is your question
james you're there
yeah it's a little bit laggy thank you
for having me
mr richard just one question um
because dan valzerian um
he had a better reputation or something
like as he i don't know if he was a life
coach but
i wanna um hire a life coach
i i just wanna know how like when it
comes to betting your guru
i think you touched upon that on rule 0
or something like that remember
[Music]
i don't think i was on that episode
so you want to hire dan bilzerian as a
life coach
no no no no i'm just saying because like
there's a lot of fakes
how do i spot one since like you're a
good established
guru like or um what do you need a
teacher i just
want to know how could i get like i
so that i won't get scammed or something
like that sir what do you need help with
um mostly like um
engineering and stuff like that like for
software
i'm barely starting out on coding like
coding apps
okay i'm still not clear on what it is
that you're trying to solve like what is
the problem that
you're trying to solve oh yeah yeah
like so that uh oh yeah
so before you ask about vetting your
guru or how to
avoid getting scammed you should be
clear on what problem it is that you're
trying to solve
oh well just that on just vetting just
waiting people in general
and also since i'm on the coding side
just
also that okay so you're like more
experienced
so what it boils down to me before i
hire anybody
to offer me any kind of advice on a
topic that i'm seeking
answers on first i'll ask my friends hey
this is what i'm stuck on
i need somebody that can help solve this
problem who who is it that you can
recommend
and then what i'll do is i'll take a
look at them and then i'll ask myself
if this person is truly an expert in the
topic that they're an expert on
where's their proven track record of
success would i want to trade my life
with
you know for them i mean if
if i'm looking for somebody to make me
like if i'm already a seven fil seven
figure
millionaire and i want to become an
eight figure millionaire
i wanna look at an eight phil eight
figure millionaire and say okay
can this person show me how to get from
a seven figure position to an eight
figure position
and are they truthfully an eight-figure
position millionaire
that's what i would be looking right
would i exchange my life for their life
are they better off than me do they
actually know what they're talking about
do they have a proven track record of
success
because [ __ ] baffles brains and
there's a lot of [ __ ] scammers out
there
on you know the youtubes even in the
space in like
you know if if you want to call it the
manosphere or the red pill space or
whatever
there's a lot of scammers out there that
like to sell
crap and stories to people that aren't
bright enough to understand that they're
full of crap if you know what i'm saying
um and they do quite well with selling
selling some of the crap but
i can look at anybody like i can
basically look at anybody's life
you know their social media feed if
they're a youtuber i can look at their
life
and i can tell you if they're full of
[ __ ] or not with with
probably about 90 accuracy right
it's just a skill that that you know you
hone over time
after being burned by some people how
old are you
29 29 okay so by 29 you should be
getting better at this
if you're 20 and you've been burned like
once or twice it'd be like okay
you know consider that a thousand two
thousand dollar lesson you just went to
school and you got schooled
right but if it keeps happening into
your 30s over and over again
you're doing something wrong like you
have to hone the skill of like vetting
these like people that are making
promises to you
yeah thank you mr richard you know i
thought i'd check in since you're more
experienced
and now with your um advice i could like
get a better um clear okay clear
thoughts over this
thank you man thanks
you